quand je vois le nucléaire comme un
amortisseur de la décroissance plus
efficace que l'éolien ou le solaire et
amortir la décroissance quand on est
dans un monde instable
c'est diminuer les risques parce que
sinon la décroissance subie et rapide ça
se termine à mort marie bonjour je
m'appelle jean marc jancovici je suis
associé dans une société qui s'appelle
carbone 4 je suis président d'une
association que certaines de shit
project je suis professeur à mines
paristech les membres du haut conseil
pour le climat
[Musique]
le contexte dans lequel il faut penser
au nucléaire c'est un contexte dans
lequel on est 8 milliards sur terre où
on a commencé à faire de gros dégâts
pas aussi clair concernant
l'environnement on prend tout ce qu'on
trouve dans le grand placard qui
s'appelle la planète terre et puis on
prend également la terre pour une grande
poubelle dans cette affaire là le
nucléaire pour moi si on s'en sert pour
remplacer autre chose est-ce que
globalement ça abaisse le niveau de
pression ou est-ce que ça l'augmentent
alors il ya un premier niveau de débat
qui est le nucléaire versus les énergies
fossiles
si je fais du nucléaire plutôt que de
faire du charbon est-ce que globalement
jeu des risques l'avenir dans la réponse
est oui et alors il ya un deuxième
niveau de débarrer qui est plus subtile
qui est est ce que si je fais du
nucléaire plutôt que de faire de
l'éolien ou du solaire jeu des risques
l'avenir et ma réponse est aussi oui et
alors là elle est évidemment plus
compliqué argumenté parce que c'est pas
du tout
l'idée qu'on en a
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une course
contre la montre si on pense aux
changements climatiques
en fait nous avons trente ans pour que
les émissions planétaires soit divisée
par 3 la raison pour laquelle on sait
goberger l'énergie fossile c'est parce
que ça permet de mettre en route un
énorme d'exosquelette et de voitures
d'avions de laminoir de four à verre de
tourniquets tafer la vinaigrette
comme disait bien et ces machines
fonctionnent pour l'essentiel avec des
énergies fossiles et se débarrasser de
l'essentiel de ces énergies fossiles
c'est se mettre au régime et le
nucléaire dans cette histoire c'est
quelque chose qui adoucit le régime et
salades ou six plus vite que les
énergies renouvelables auxquelles on
pense c'est à dire éolien et solaire
parce que ça utilise une énergie
beaucoup plus concentrés et on peut s'en
servir quand on en a besoin
alors que les éoliennes et le solaire
utilisent des énergies très diffuses
dire qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup d'énergie
dans un mètre cube de vent qui se
déplace il n'y a pas beaucoup d'énergie
dans un mètre carré est exposé au soleil
donc collecter ces énergies et les
concentrés c'est très coûteux en moyens
et si on choisit la voie de l'éolien et
du solaire plutôt du nucléaire il va
nous falloir en gros 10 fois plus de
temps pour arriver à supprimer la partie
de l'énergie fossile qu'on arrivera à
supprimer avec ces énergies décarbonées
avec les énergies renouvelables un moyen
identique on aura quelque chose de
beaucoup plus faible et donc la
suppression des combustibles fossiles
nous fera chuter beaucoup plus
lourdement
il créera des discussions sociales et
des disruption économique beaucoup plus
forte
en gros je vois le nucléaire comme un
amortisseur de la décroissance plus
efficace que l'éolien ou le solaire
[Musique]
on va y avoir droit de toute façon parce
que la terre est finie et que une
population croissante sur une terre
finit avec une consommation croissante à
personne ça marche pas indéfiniment donc
après l'expansion arrivera la
contraction
c'est absolument inexorable ce qui vient
de se passer avec le coville est une
très bonne illustration du type de
processus qui vont se mettre en route
quand la phase de contraction vraiment
des mariés ça sera des chocs
donc les gens qui sont à la fois anti
combustibles fossiles et antinucléaires
en fait ils sont en train d'accepter
l'idée que plutôt que de diviser le
pouvoir d'achat par trois on va diviser
par dix moi je veux bien si c'est ça que
les gens veulent votre problématique
celui-là on évoquera je ne suis pas
complètement sûr que les gens aient
compris que c'était ça qu'on achetait
[Musique]
on vit aujourd'hui dans un monde dans
lequel nos techniques du quotidien nous
échappe
c'est dire qu'on se sert au quotidien
d'un milliard d'appareils et on est
infoutue et d'en comprendre le
fonctionnement du coup ça ouvre la voie
à tous les fantasmes à toutes les
théories du complot à tous les
quiproquos à toutes les erreurs de bonne
ou de mauvaise foi ce qui est frustrant
aujourd'hui c'est de voir à quel point
on passe beaucoup trop de temps à
essayer de corriger les choses fausses
au lieu de débattre de ce qu'on fait sur
la base des choses vraies d'avoir une
presse qui confond trop souvent un fait
et une opinion on peut débattre des
opinions on ne peut pas débattre des
faits toutes les filières industrielles
nucléaires compris ont connu des
accidents et des drames dans le domaine
des barrages il ya eu deux gros
accidents en europe il ya eu la rupture
du barrage de fréjus en france dans les
années 50 qui a fait entre 400 et 500
morts
il ya eu un glissement de terrain dans
le lac de retenue du barrage de long
garonne en italie qui a fait 2500 morts
il n'y a pas un accident nucléaire en
europe par même tchernobyl qui ait fait
autant de morts pourtant les barrages
pour pas mauvaise presse
le charbon en europe alors maintenant il
commence un peu à avoir mauvaise presse
mais affecte considérablement plus de
morts en europe que n'importe quelle
autre forme d'énergie
il n'ya pas sortir du charbon ça
n'existe pas comme association
[Musique]